welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and just when you think the sick
minds behind Avengers endgame and
infinity war have gone darken up with
rejected story idea it's about Thanos
decapping cap Marvel head Kevin Feige
makes a wall cameo to explain how things
were almost far more sickening how did
fieger's make us all feel super
uncomfortable this news cycle and what
does it tell us about the alternate
directions Avengers in game almost went
and how those directions would have
altered other ultimate directions that
we thought they in-game story almost
went spoiler warning because not saying
so feels like not putting on a seatbelt
and sometimes a jerk around so much
these episodes I get motion sickness so
buckle in and let's break this down okay
in response to the end game
screenwriters Eminem gushing about
morbid alternate scene ideas at Comic
Con and the in-game directors are an RPR
Lavin in a reddit AMA about supposedly
still hidden Easter eggs
yeah okay or I guess I'll just watch it
for the 3,000 time wolf I Gertz gave an
interview of his own revealing that not
only was the screenwriters idea of
Thanos decapitating cap a legit concept
that they considered for the film that
concept art of this image existed and it
depicted a different timeline and went
in a much darker direction here's what
he said enjoy the impression I think
there are behind scenes pictures of this
us having the giant omnibus of the
Infinity Gauntlet collection and saying
we need to do justice to this one of
those was Thanos sitting on a throne of
skulls ruling over everything and we
wanted to get that in there one of the
ideas was when they finished the time
heist they returned to a world in 2023
the thinest had already conquered that
involved all that and the throne made of
bones and skulls and had him tossing
like a bowling ball Captain America
severed skull head still in the cowl and
it was pretty cool but the logic to get
there defeated us bracket end impression
for now when asked how close this got to
appearing on screen Fieger said and
diving back into the voice here forgive
me I think it hadn't up and a set of
pages at one point in the script there
might have been a piece of concept art
somewhere with it oh man oh and Wow we
don't yet have any official Marvel
Studios concept art this idea might have
been inspired by the image of Thanos by
comic book artist Jim Cheung super
gnarly I just love that Feige went into
further description of this imagery
tossing caps
like a bowling ball a skull of it still
in the cow which means he must have cut
off caps head remove the cow held onto
it peeled all of the tissue off of the
skull and then put the cow back on like
a jack-o'-lantern lid
yeah insane and yes a throne of skulls
we'll talk about how weird that fern
would be in a bit but as a nerd here's
what I find most interesting about Feige
zal old description according to him
Thanos was already waiting for the
Avengers back in the present day by the
time they return from their time heist
like Thanos got back there first but in
the version of the scene described by
the screenwriters Thanos decapitated cap
from a different timeline his original
source timeline in 2014
wrecking earth in that timeline and
let's not forget leaving the giant
shit-stained corpse of Hank Pym swirled
across the landscape their words Rimmer
Eminem said had knowing it would take
some time and so he went down to his
present day so then Danice would jump
from that point in history to the
present day toeing along caps rotting
severed head putting it or I guess yeah
pulling the strike with it to freak out
the recently returned The Avengers and
say I killed all you once I can kill you
again but with this idea of a throne of
skulls in 2023 Feige is saying that
Thanos must have done some additional
slain in the present day while he was
waiting for them to finish the time high
score like he killed a bunch of people
in 2014 and then carried all of their
skulls and bones into the future which
would be a pretty annoying Shore for the
Black Order and the outriders SIA this
goes the heavy and wanted Kerry kid
would just leave them here in the past I
want production value I want my bone
thrown but if Thanos Dave get these
skulls from the present-day which of the
humans on earth at that time could have
been among the victims Pepper Potts and
Cassie Lange for him in the arm breasts
Okoye and Baku form in the back
thanos popping his squat Lynne hot ones
into the skull of happy Hogan yeah I
guess we aren't sure if this would be
the literal skulls of the Dead but
rather like a creepy illusion that
Thanos would to conjure using the
reality stone because Feige also went on
to explain I'm back at the voice here I
will keep opening the book and saying we
need something like this Thanos can do
this some of that led to things that you
saw on infinity war and nowhere where he
turns Drax into a pile of cubes or he
turns nebula into that spiraling ribbon
or as bubbles come out of star Ward's
gun it's casual sadistic use of the
stones
was something that we kept wanting to do
so essentially these skull throne was
intended to be a kind of mind game by
Thanos based on how the reality stone
seems to operate in other ways and
infinity war you know it seems to
manipulate reality in the form of
temporary illusions like like Jackson
abox mantis into ribbons quills
blaster-bolt in the bubbles and when
Thanos left nowhere with Gamora all of
that went back to normal and by the way
it totally didn't need to the reality
stone is an infinity stone when an
infinity stone warps reality to make you
blocks this should stay blocks but it
sounds as though in these older versions
of the Infinity Warren endgame scripts
the reality stone had a much darker
permanence to its effects it's possible
that the skulls of thanasis throne were
going to be actual skulls of characters
we knew of other past victims of his or
skulls he summoned from nearby graves in
any case still super morbid and in no
way comfortable to sit on do you think
Dana should have gotten his bone thrown
in Avengers endgame and you wish the
reality stone was used in more
interesting ways than blocks ribbons and
bubbles comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter ID a vos and subscribe to me
rock starts to break downs in theories
about everything Marvel thank you for
joining me and while writing this
episode I no joke wrote the word skull
as scroll pretty much every time that's
right I still haven't given up on my
scroll search and I will not stop until
I find whose scroll is the skull a
reverse that all that went back to
normal
and by the way it totally didn't need to
reality stone is in a bit